[Música]
[Aplausos]
boa noite
as redes sociais elas transformaram as
regras de comunicação colocando todas as
pessoas com acesso à internet em
condições muito semelhantes o que
significa que um garoto de 16 anos que
faz mesmo pelo celular ele pode alcançar
muito mais pessoas do que alguém com
doutorado em um complexo jornalístico
eu não estou dizendo que academicismo
não seja importante é mas se essa
informação não alcança periferia ela não
alcançam interior
ela não alcança quem está fora desse
círculo acadêmico alguma outra pessoa
alcançar e vai alcançar às vezes com o
mesmo de uma frase que vai fazer o
ouvinte mudar de ideia e concordar com
ela
só que no campo das eleições onde cada
cidadão ele representa só um voto um
garoto de 16 anos e um doutor em
ciências políticas e eles têm o mesmo
peso e isso faz toda diferença
existe um fenômeno que é muito presente
nas interações digitais que ele se chama
efeito bolha agentes sociais elas
trabalham em cima de uma plataforma
numérica o facebook o twitter o
instagram eles enxergam a nossa
interação como um fluxo de rede é o que
você curte o que você comenta o que você
compartilha quem você segue e quem você
adiciona e isso tudo é matemática é
número que a audiência e também dinheiro
então a plataforma ela é programada para
entregar o que mediante a sua interação
é o que você mais gosta de ler comentar
curtir e é isso forma bolhas porque
quanto mais você usa plataforma mais
você só se relaciona com quem concorda
contigo
um dos casos mais recentes do uso dessas
bolhas para atender interesses
individuais foram as últimas eleições
nos estados unidos quando o time foi
eleito
os jornais eles apontaram os
de dados privados para poder atender ou
pra poder manipular eleitores que
estavam indecisos e como isso aconteceu
hoje quase ninguém conhece melhor do que
seu celular
nem a sua esposa nem o seu melhor amigo
muitas vezes nem mesmo você é o celular
que sabe quem você gosta é o celular que
sabe com quem você se relaciona ele sabe
quanto você ganha ele sabe os seus
rascunhos
eles sabem suas senhas e principalmente
o celular conhece seus medos
ele conhece a aba oculta que você acha
de madrugada ele conhece ele sabe onde
estão seus pontos fracos
e como é que isso foi usado notícia
estavam sendo jogados diretamente para
americanos que estavam desempregados que
logo depois recebeu informações do
candidato que propunha a construção de
um muro para poder conter os imigrantes
antes mesmo disso já tinham notícias por
exemplo de que o obama era muçulmano
sendo entregue pra americanos que
interagiam com o terrorismo que tinham
medo daquilo e no brasil não foi muito
diferente onde eu quero chegar com tudo
isso que a gente na maioria das vezes
tem a certeza de que nós estamos usando
as redes sociais aplicativos quando na
verdade não seria o contrário
e quanto mais você usa a plataforma
quanto mais você bloqueia pessoas e
quanto mais você se cerca só de quem
concorda com tigo mais vulnerável você
fica e mais fácil é de manipular existe
um estudo chamado digital news o esporte
do instituto reuters em parceria com a
universidade de oxford que ele já
apontava há dez anos que a principal
fonte de informação da sociedade é o
celular e não mais a tv
isso nos estados unidos no brasil vem
acontecendo gradativamente
outra informação muito importante é que
as pessoas elas se importam muito mais
com a emoção que não se atrás do que de
fato com a fonte ea realidade disso é
nossa na nossa sociedade hoje pessoas
cada vez mais com menos paciência -
emocional pessoas cada vez mais lendo
hoje as mesmas fontes
e é isso
existe um estudo da inicial a
universidade universidade de londres que
correlaciona isso diretamente com o
acrescente absurda dos casos de suicídio
depressão ansiedade e jovens pelo mundo
todo
o uso enfim essa imersão nas bolhas das
redes sociais
a neurociência ela diz que nós
instintivamente supervalorizamos o
julgamento que dão certo e sub
valorizamos os que dão errado o que
significa que a gente quase sempre têm a
certeza de que tenha razão como na
verdade ao contrário eu desenhar 16 aqui
no chão para vocês aí pra você vai ser
nova ou errado de não sei se não todos
estão errados está vendo 9 também não só
que aí entra o último ingrediente dessa
receita bomba
sete em cada dez estudantes do ensino
médio hoje no brasil estão saindo das
escolas com nível insuficiente de
português
meninos e meninas de 16 17 18 anos estão
saindo das escolas sem a capacidade de
interpretar de localizar informações nos
artigos de separar opiniões de fatos
então a gente tem uma mistura de pessoas
desempregadas se uma dificuldade no
acesso à educação básica de qualidade
deprimidas que pensam o tempo inteiro
que tem razão e que passa uma outra boa
parte do tempo consumindo notícias
falsas bom organização política
questionamento dos direitos básicos
humanos
a agressão não tem meio termo ou você é
fascista que é torturar todo mundo
ou você é comunista e tem que ir a cuba
não tem meio termo onde foi a nossa
capacidade de dialogar é a dirigindo
gerindo essa página e enfim tocando essa
página de 3 milhões de seguidores e que
todo dia abordando pautas polêmicas e eu
acabei percebendo um outro efeito que é
um dos principais nessa polarização que
a gente vive hoje eu chamo ele de
o efeito rebote e como é que ele
funciona hoje a gente vive a uma época
onde onde as pessoas se sentem cada vez
mais na obrigação de fazer com que
outras pessoas pensem como elas
e nesse desespero tite de combater esse
inimigo sabe invisível e de catequizar
pessoas elas só compartilham o que tem
de mais extremos de cada lado na
tentativa de converter todas as pessoas
as meias da outra ponta na prática é
assim alguém liberal abre o telefone e
aí chega uma notícia de que todo o
conservador é torturador
ele vai lá e compartilha sem nem checar
a fonte
o cara que é conservador vai abrir
também a rede social vai ter pela
notícia e não vai gostar dela que o cara
não vai se identificava com essa coisa
nunca torturou ninguém está errado o que
vai acontecer se no telefone desse
conservador cinco minutos depois
apareceu uma notícia de que todo liberal
é pedófilo
ele vai compartilhar e é esse o maior
combustível dos pequeninos é querer
torturar pessoas ou é querer converter
pessoas e converter a força aí você
enfim a gente pode estar se perguntando
e ver como que a gente faz para poder se
comunicar com pessoas que não estão
dispostas a ouvir o que a gente tem pra
falar eu não tenho uma fórmula mágica
mas o que eu posso afirmar é que a gente
não pode mais se comunicar com na década
de 90
e olha você não vinha bem mas eu estudei
como na década de 90 que você imprimir o
material que foi criado o conteúdo
imprimia colava e fazia as pessoas lerem
aquilo a força empurrando goela abaixo
lei pelo amor de deus isso não funciona
mais não funciona porque porque as
pessoas têm cada vez menos tempo e as
notícias têm cada vez uma oferta maior
então elas só vão ler o que para elas
venha de fato de uma fonte ou de alguém
interessante então se comunicar hoje
depende diretamente da sua capacidade de
se tornar uma pessoa interessante em ser
ouvida
o caminho que a gente encontrou para
isso foi
esses cinco itens comunicação não
violenta falar sem agredir o outro
empatia tentar entender a realidade do
outro conhecimento saber do que a gente
está falando credibilidade postar
notícias de fontes confiáveis e checar e
tato para falar com pessoas e
sentimentos que nós somos seres humanos
somos muito complexos
há uma estratégia que a gente encontrou
que é muito boa pra isso é você
conseguir trabalhar encontrar um algum
ponto de conexão com seu ouvinte é você
trabalhar há uma comunicação que
encontre uma conexão com quem está
sozinho ea gente encontrou isso nos
nossos elos nos nossos pontos humanos
união e quais são eles
humanidade dignidade respeito
oportunidade trabalho dinheiro todo
mundo quer ser respeitado
todo mundo quer ter oportunidade todo
mundo quer ter uma vida digna então esse
é o ponto em comum
entende se alguém o qual é a idéia de
vocês quando eu digo o eu sou defensor
dos direitos humanos que é nessa hora
que muita gente me coloca numa caixinha
do estereótipo de defensor de bandido
quando na verdade não é nada disso
então se alguém chega pra mim fala por
você defensor de bandido não sou você
não sou a gente não vai chegar um ponto
no mundo vai falar que eu sou eu falar
que eu não sou
então como é que a gente faz pra
conseguir a atenção desse ouvinte
todo mundo aqui tem criança em casa na
família
acho que eu não tenho um sobrinho filho
eles são muito bonitinhos e eu tenho eu
tenho em casa que a gente briga todo dia
brincadeira mas briga acho que ninguém
aqui concorda que crianças devam passar
fome ou sente sede correto tem alguém aí
por isso é ninguém né tá bom então se
você defende que crianças mereçam água e
comida você é um defensor dos direitos
humanos vocês entendem como a gente cria
um ponto de conexão encontrar um álbum
elo que a pessoa vai convergir
pensamento contigo
isso é nessa hora que você consegue a
atenção do outro por exemplo
op é muito diferente a uma pessoa chegar
e falar uns por você escuta uma opinião
muito diferente que você nunca viu na
vida
é muito diferente você vir a pessoa
falar poxa você é um burro e ignorante e
cala sua boca do que você usar caramba
eu nunca ouvi essa informação que é de
onde você tirou é muito diferente é
muito diferente uma pessoa falar com
você a uma pessoa fazer alguma besteira
e você fala caramba eu te disse que isso
aconteça que isso ia acontecer com você
falar poxa da próxima vez a gente tenta
de uma forma diferente
está tudo certo ou então você não querer
mais discutir aquele assunto e falar não
quero mais falar com você com você usar
poxa gente pode retomar essa conversa
uma outra hora comunicação não violenta
é isso é tentar se comunicar de uma
forma que não agrida outra pessoa é
mostrar para ela que vocês não tão times
opostos que se colocam pra você vai ser
bom pra ela fazer ela entender que vocês
convergem alguma coisa que vocês são
humanos tinha uma frase que eu tinha
escutado muito tempo achava legal é que
o humano que não defende direitos
humanos é como uma árvore que defende o
desmatamento não tem não tem lógica
nenhuma aí eu trouxe tá aí né
obrigado vamos lá e é importante a gente
entender a necessidade de se reeducar na
forma de se comunicar e da importância
da comunicação não violenta
principalmente a na realidade que a
gente vive hoje a gente o brasil é o
país que mais mata lgbt no mundo
a gente também tem o quinto maior índice
de feminicídio do mundo não são pessoas
morreram em um atropelamento não são
pessoas morreram afogadas são pessoas
sendo mortas só por ser quem elas são
por serem lgbt expor a marca pessoas e
fui por serem mulheres
a gente tem um registro formal na 2º
fórum de segurança pública que no brasil
ocorram 60 mil estupros por ano e o que
mais choca é que só um em cada dez
estupros vira bell chegam até a polícia
chegou até o hospital e você sabe por
quê
por que sete em cada dez vítimas de
estupros são crianças que estão sendo
estupradas de dentro de casa por
familiares ou pessoas que freqüentam as
casas todo mundo com essa imagem mês
passado aconteceu isso
um segurança se achou no direito de
estrangula um jovem negro dentro de um
supermercado até a morte
semana passada no né não tem muito tempo
de diferença de um para o outro todo
mundo com essa imagem
uma família estava indo para um chá de
bebê na família negra pobre e foi
fuzilada com 80 tiros do exército e às
vezes não preciso nem trazer essas
imagens para poder mostrar que caramba
será que racismo existe mesmo anos né eu
nem sua pessoa pra falar isso mas é
porque ela pode se apresentar de forma
muito mais sutis e aí que a gente gosta
de trabalhar por exemplo quantas contas
das pessoas aqui já foram atendidas por
médicos negros é difícil né aí uma
pessoa do juiz
é por isso que a gente defende a quebra
de tabus é por isso que a gente defende
uma sociedade com mais informação e
menos careta é por isso que a gente
defende que cada cidadão ele tem que ter
a sua voz preservada e valorizada é por
isso que a gente defende que mulheres
entrem na política que só elas entendem
a realidade delas é por isso que a gente
defende educação sexual nas escolas que
não é colocar um filme pornô com uma
criança de cinco anos mas é apresentar
as principais vítimas de estupro o que
são áreas íntimas que elas não podem ser
tocadas ensinar para as crianças como se
defender como denunciar é por isso que a
gente defende sistema de cotas
num país que tem a maioria negra e eles
não estão em posições de destaque na
sociedade
é por isso que a gente defende o
feminismo que promove a desigualdade
salarial e que sobrecarrega mulheres
enquanto privilegia homens
é por isso que a gente defende de
educação
a gente defende porque não dá mais não
dá mais pra você apontar
o dedo para o outro e falar olha resolve
isso porque não existe mais problema do
outro existe um problema nosso e por
mais que a gente não nunca tenha
cometido bullying ou mais que a gente
nunca tenha discriminado alguém pouco de
pele ou por orientação sexual os
problemas eles existem
a gente vive em sociedade e se a gente
não se reeducar na nossa forma de se
comunicar os problemas só vão ficar
maiores ea mensagem mais importante que
eu tenho pra deixar aqui hoje é que
vocês não precisam de três milhões de
seguidores para fazer a diferença
obrigado
[Aplausos]